depuis la mi-novembre 4 cas de
streptocoque du groupe A ont été
répertoriés chez les enfants par la
santé publique de Montréal deux d'entre
eux se sont avérés mortels
qui produit des toxines si les
streptocoques du groupe a entraînent le
couramment des maladies bénignes comme
des infections de la gorge elle peuvent
dans de rares cas cause une maladie plus
grave des symptômes éprouvants les
éruptions cutanées les vomissements et
les diarrhées ne sont pas des symptômes
classiques entre 2017 et 2021 il n'y a
pourtant jamais eu plus d'un cas par
année dans la métropole comment donc
expliquer cette augmentation une
situation qui n'est pas étrangère au cas
de grippe qui ont explosé au Québec la
grippe donne l'opportunité à cette
bactérie là d'invahir les tissus de la
gorge et des poumons ça prend une
dizaine de minutes on a le résultat dans
certaines pharmacies de la province il
est même possible de se faire dépister
dans l'espoir de freiner la progression
de la bactérie on peut prescrire des
antibiotiques un traitement
conforme au dossier du passé quand on
prend un traitement antibiotique en 24
heures ça enlève la contagion devant
cette augmentation c'est infectiologue
pé pris par un et enfin de prendre leur
précautions
éviter la première infection virale
évitez la grippe éviter ça il y a un
moyen qu'on peut faire facilement
faites-vous vacciner contre la grippe un
appel à la vaccination qui a été entendu
par cette mer et il y a un nouveau-né
moi c'est sûr que je fais attention puis
mon conjoint il greffé du foie il faut
qu'on fasse attention aux bactéries qui
rentrent dans la maison de son côté le
cabinet du ministre de la Santé d'y
suivre de très près la situation avec
les autorités de santé publique nos
premières pensées vont famille toucher
écrit-on on a confiance au travail
effectué par la direction régionale de
la santé publique ici elles disent c'est
une Radio-Canada Montréal